[Musique]
je vais commencer par une anecdote en
octobre 2012
je travaillais sur un site en allemagne
et mon chef de l'époque très content de
mon travail me propose une augmentation
de 12 % la moyenne dans l'entreprise
était de 3% alors sachant que c'était
bien plus haut que la moyenne
il a dû passer par par beaucoup de
paperasse pour faire accepter ses 12 %
l'information arrive sur mes collègues
en france devinez ce que j'ai ce que
j'ai pu avoir comme commentaire
quelqu'un a une idée exactement ça donc
des préjugés des clichés des défis j'ai
un enfant tu es dans ma carrière
professionnelle
par contre pas une fois je me suis
découragée pas une fois je ne le suis je
me suis laissé abattre et j'ai fait
preuve de créativité
j'ai continué à avancer et c'est pour ça
et c'est comme ça que je suis là où j'en
suis
tout cela pour moi c'est la force de la
résilience cette force même qui permet
ce qui permet aux femmes d'être
d'avancer dans un milieu qui encore très
dominés par le masculin n'était pas mon
expérience personnelle j'ai deux
messages à faire passer
donc c'est des messages
c'est le message qui me paraissent
importants le premier message est à voir
françois et avancer avancer peu importe
les préjugés ce que je ferai c'est que
pour chaque message
j'aurai trois exemples qui sont là pour
illustrer le message trois exemples qui
seront tirés de mon expérience
personnelle donc dans le premier exemple
je vous parlerai des clichés auxquels
j'ai eu à faire face dans un milieu qui
est très technique
notre le monde automobile dans lequel
j'évolue et est un monde très
industrielle et il ya encore beaucoup de
personnes qui pensent qu'une voiture
c'est masculin
je me souviens par exemple de collègues
qui en voulant expliquer les modèles de
voitures nous regardent et de nos très
suspicieux en le disant
à qui ça va à qui tu comprends c'est
comme si je vous disais mais j'ai un peu
son cousin savonner pas fait de la même
manière que les leurs c'est un peu ce
qu'ils pensaient alors que pour moi
quand on est quand on m'explique les
choses je suis à même de comprendre si
on m'explique bien les choses de manière
claire et définie
alors mais plutôt de me laisser abattre
vous démoraliser par ses petites piques
j'ai décidé d'en savoir plus sur la
technique alors je me suis rapproché
d'ingénieur en technique qui eux
n'avaient pas là priori sur mes
capacités on va dire intellectuelle ça
m'a pris du temps je suis arrivé très
tôt certains matins j'ai fini de faire
pas mal de soirées
mais le résultat est que je me suis
beaucoup formés à la technique et que ça
a donné une autre dimension d'un conflit
financier
c'est cet exemple pour dire que
finalement plutôt que de me laisser
abattre par les critiques par les
préjugés
j'ai continué d'avancer et dans la
prendre plus ensuite je vais vous donner
un deuxième exemple qui va être par
rapport à la maternité
je suis une maman d'une petite fille de
5 ans et comme l'annoncent ma grossesse
avant à mon chef de l'époque à
l'allemand qui est basé au siège
il me dit hein c'est dommage j'avais une
convention pour toi je vais dîner
pourquoi c'est dommage
une vie mais maintenant tu vas t'occuper
de ta fille et ça me paraissait évident
donc sur le coup ça m'a affecté
je suis passé au dessus je me suis
concentré sur ma grossesse
et je suis content je suis revenu
travailler par contre l'opportunité
d'avancer n'existait plus et c'est mais
par contre je alors plutôt que de
mensonges acceptaient le fait que pour
certains managers la vision qu'ils
avaient deux mois avait changé depuis ma
maternité et j'ai d'essayer d'avancer
autrement alors j'ai repris mes études
j'ai repris un master en relations
internationales et finalement et j'étais
assez ferme lorsque je me suis rendu
compte que finalement être maman c'est
pas du tout un frein mais c'est
justement quelque chose qu'on peut
concilier avec une vie professionnelle
en plus être vin m'a permis d'être
beaucoup plus efficace dans mon
quotidien
ce que j'ai dû gérer une petite fille
qui a des problèmes de santé
un travail aussi les études tout ça en
europe sachant qu'on n'a pas des profits
mais quand la palette domestiquant à
l'europe donc pareil pour ce deuxième
exemple plutôt que de quelque part de
stagner et de me laisser abattre ou de
ne pas évoluer de par certains préjugés
je décide d'y croire encore de garder
mes ambitions et de me donner les moyens
d'y arriver seul différemment que je
donne quand même ces moyens-là d'y
arriver
ensuite le troisième et dernier exemple
pour pour illustrer vend toujours ce
message qui est de croire en soi et de
et d'avancer peu un penser que les
préjugés on va dire qu'il est lié aux
qualités soient perçus comme féminine
donc à la fin de la mission évoqué dans
le post un peu enfin dont je vous
parlais avec les 12 % d'augmentation
je devais évoluer dans la pause
responsable financière du site
c'était un site assez important avec un
chiffonnier armorial de 200 milliards de
cfa et je devais en quarts et toute
l'équipe financière et comptable ce paul
joe responsable financière dépendait du
directeur de l'usiné et c'est là que
j'affrontais un défi lié soit disant à
mes qualités féminines
pour le directeur de l'usiné la
condition pour que je le poste et que la
plupart des équipes aient peur de moi
c'était pour lui la mère de se faire
respecter dans un monde très masculin
par contre ça n'allait pas parce que je
ne sais pas du tout ma nature je suis
plutôt radiant bienveillante plutôt
empathique
ceux qui continueraient condé comme des
qualités féminines qui ne vont pas du
tout avec un monde industriel masculin
j'ai quand même voulu essayer j'arrivais
pas et ça ne marchait pas en plus donc
je suis pas mal de personnes à dos en
plus je n'avais pas les informations que
je devais abord attend alors ce que je
sais c'est pas évident comme comme comme
époque mais plutôt que de continuer à
cette personne qu'on me demander d'être
je me suis dit j'arrête là et je vais
vers d'autres choses je verse que je
suis moi donc j'ai évolué dans notre
poste qui me correspondait plus et
finalement ça s'est très bien passé
parce que c'est le poste que j'utilise
un que j'occupais jusqu'à deux semaines
ceux comme je suis parti j'ai quand même
la directrice financière qui au siège
qui m'a dit qui m'a dit que c'était
dommage que je parle parce que je suis
guinéen contrôleuse ce qu'il ya c'est
qu'avec ces natures empathique
j'arrivais à avoir des informations
beaucoup plus rapidement que beaucoup de
collègues qu'elle est beaucoup plus à
qui était beaucoup plus agressif et ce
qu'il faut retenir aussi c'est que pour
des ses qualités soi-disant empathique
pour le forum économique mondial ça va
être les qualités indispensables pour
les leaders de demain
ensuite tous ces exemples pour vous dire
que peu importe ce que les deux autres
nous dirons nous reprocheront en tant
que femme je pense qu'il est important
de
se laisser abattre par les préjugés
d'être conscients de nos qualités de
trouver le moyen d'être valorisé quitte
à changer de poste ou à se relancer dans
des formations
ensuite le deuxième message que j'ai à
faire passer et qu'il faut oser être et
qu'il faut oser faire entendre sa voix
et s'exprimer donc où tout comme
précédemment
je vais partir d'exemples pour le
premier exemple je vais remonter à bien
plus longtemps à mon premier job et là
je me souviens d'une réunion pendant
laquelle j'étais censé présenter les
avancements de sur un projet dont
j'étais pilote
j'avais tout préparé mais je ne vais pas
me mettre en avant
auparavant j'avais eu la bonne idée de
partager tous les avancements avec un
collègue
et devinez ce qui s'est passé pendant la
réunion il a tout il a tout
effectivement il a tout rires là son
concours ces salive de paix valoriser
sur le coup j'ai trouvé ça injuste et ça
m'est resté en tête quand pendant un
petit bout de temps il n'y a que depuis
quelques années que j'ai compris que
c'était à moi de faire valoir toutes mes
idées
le monde de l'entreprise est un vin sans
pitié le plus souvent et je pense qu'en
tant que femme on ne se valorisent pas
toujours on va le mettre les autres
avant on va mettre l'équipe en avant
mais se vendre soit on le fera très
rarement et je pense que pour éviter
d'être frustré il faut qu'on apprenne à
vendre ce qu'on a fait à m à nous mettre
en avant et en autre motion si nous ne
mettons pas en avant on ne peut pas
attendre les autres qu'ils le fassent
enfin pour ce deuxième message qui est
de doser s'exprimer j'ai un deuxième et
dernier exemple
qui on va dire peut-être un peu plus
délicat en général jean py indien jamais
inclinés d'au moins un agent bien être
coquette ans dans l'entreprise où
j'étais cela m'a valu beaucoup d' avance
de propositions que je trouvais sont
dégoûtantes de la boule de collègues
masculins dirigeants ou pas d'ailleurs
j'avais systématiquement des
commentaires sur mes habits la manière
de maquiller sur le sur la coiffure
en plus je travaille en france et là
vous savez on se fait la bise pour se
saluer alors il y avait quand même d y
avait des personnes qui avaient cette
habitude de se rapprocher vraiment très
proches ou faire la bise et ça qu'ils
soient et ça qu'ils soient manager ou
pas c'était la même chose c'est beaucoup
de gomme
mais par contre ça me dégoûte est je
suis quand même passé par une phase qui
n'était pas évidente parce que à un
moment je me suis dit j'ai commencé à
vouloir changer la manière de m'habiller
pour ne pas avoir à subir justement ces
problèmes là et c'est un parlant avec
des collègues qui avait vécu la même
chose que finalement je me suis rendu
compte que je n'étais pas la seule
et quelque part de parler assez de
parler à ces femmes m'a donné le
sentiment de ne plus être seul et cette
force de pouvoir dire non je me suis dit
que fin et j'ai continué à être comme
j'étais tout en pouvant tout en ayant la
force de dire non à ces personnes qui
effectivement se permettait des
jugements qui était pas du fait des
commentaires qui était très très douteux
on va dire en fait je pense qu il ya
longtemps très important de s'exprimer
et de dire les choses
j'ai oublie toujours que quelque part il
ya quelqu'un qui vit les mêmes challenge
que nous qui vit les mêmes problèmes que
nous est de savoir qu'elle n'est pas
seule lui donne la force de continuer
justement à se battre et à savoir
exprimer ses idées
donc ça c'était mon dernier exemple
alors comme vous voyez j'ai à fonder
quelques petits obstacles
j'ai jamais baissé les bras et et ses
obsèques n'ont permis de développer des
mécanismes qui permet finalement m'ont
permis de progresser d'apprendre
énormément de choses j'étais et servi
par les parents mon père qu'il repose en
paix a tout donné au niger mais il était
enseignant à l'université de niamey où
ils croyaient déjà la renaissance du
niger
et malgré les difficultés les obstacles
ne perdez jamais espoir et continuer
d'avancer
pour lui le maître mot était la passion
sont contentés difficulté il faut être
patient positive et continuer à se
battre comme on dit à rosas sale bâtard
lazoa de meilleures choses attendent le
chaland
[Applaudissements]